she avoid new pasta being today on the
last day of the century I'm resigning no
one had seen this coming
Boris Yeltsin stepping down the former
KGB spy Vladimir Putin his chosen
successor confirmed by the public three
months later two decades on President
Putin hasn't changed much but Russia is
transformed the queues and food
shortages the trauma of the 1990s a
distant memory Chechen terrorism the
horrors of the bez land hostage crisis
and the theater siege in Moscow which
President Putin called the worst moments
of his presidency dealt with by the time
his first two terms were up then came
the job swap with Prime Minister Dmitry
Medvedev though no one really doubted
who was calling the shots and a new wave
of foreign adventurism on his return to
the presidency the little green men in
Crimea symbol of a revanchist Russia
Russia's bloody intervention in Syria
cementing the Kremlin's foothold in the
Middle East the question for this new
decade is what happens next
Putin is constitutionally required to
step down in 2020 for options in the
rumor mill or a union of Belarus and
Russia with Putin at the helm or another
caretaker stint for the man in the
middle Dmitry Medvedev true to form the
President himself is keeping it vague
your humble servant served two terms
then quit this position and had the
constitutional right to come back to the
presidency because it was not two
consecutive terms it embarrasses some of
our political scientists social
activists it might be canceled this
uncertainty has its advantages
you can play groups of interests against
each other you can hold them in this
situation of a certainty of an honest
it cannot go on for too long because it
provokes infighting within the elite
that's if bare-chested machismo can't
keep the elites at bay hugely popular
still Vladimir Putin has inspired a
fitter less vodka fueled nation his
carefully curated strongman status a
message to all those watching that when
the time comes he won't give up power
easily Diana Magnay Sky News Moscow